[Music]
hello
americans and people of
all stripes of all walks of life of all
nationalities
all over the world today
is november 2nd 2020
and right now we are one day away
from the american election will donald
trump remain the president or will
joe biden be the president
that is the choice that's what we're
left with
may god help us all here we go it's
going
to be a crazy week you can feel it like
we all know everything's kind of nuts
and locked down
and racism and everything feels crazy
and pandemics and
all of that but you could really feel it
if you're an online creature right now
if you're in the i don't know i guess
the youtube comment section
or you're on twitter or wherever you do
your thing whether you're looking at
baby pictures on
facebook which somehow devolve into a
debate about trump or just like
everything feels particularly
crazy right now and it is going to
continue to feel crazy today
all of tomorrow and for god only knows
how long
after after the election because we
don't even know if
if either side will say they lost or
either side will say they won or
will anyone have true results will
anyone trust the results i mean it
really
it really is nuts and it and it feels
like like joking aside
it does feel like the system itself is
in flux right now
uh it feels like everything's in flux
which in many ways i think was the
inevitable conclusion
of the last couple years you know of
trump coming in saying he was going to
drain the swamp
fighting the media the media fighting
back like it has all sort of led us here
doesn't it kind of feel like that if
you step back just a little bit that it
almost is like oh this is exactly
where we were going to be a day before
the election so
obviously today guys we're going to talk
plenty about
the election i also want to talk and
we're going to show you the full video
about kamala harris because she tweeted
out a video yesterday and you know i try
not to
tweet on the weekends but when the vice
president presidential candidate
goes full marxist full woke marxist
dave's got a tweet and my phone was
blowing up yesterday people were sending
me this thing and i was like i've got
to say something about it so we're going
to show you this video this very short
video it's about a minute and a half or
so
video that kamala harris posted where
she is deeply deeply deeply confused
about what america is all about and she
does not seem to understand or maybe she
does and that's even more disturbing the
difference
between equality which is what you're
guaranteed in america
and equity which is not what you're
guaranteed um
and we'll unpack that and discuss why
and then the third story i want to talk
about today
is that gretchen whitmer who is the
authoritarian very botoxed
governor of michigan she has new coveted
lockdown rules and they're going to
start taking lists people these people
love lists they love lists they're going
to start taking names
for people that show up at restaurants i
mean and then they're series of other
things and she's just been
absolutely one of the worst lockdown
governors
and it was like didn't they find her on
a boat with a bunch of friends a couple
months ago when she was trying to keep
everybody locked down
so we'll talk a little bit about that
but obviously we're going to focus
mostly on the election today
uh so i want to start and we're going to
show you a little video
uh as i'm as i'm rolling out this story
i want to start with the election and
stuff
and on saturday i went to what i suppose
will be
the final beverly hills donald trump
rally now you guys
know that two weeks ago i was at a trump
rally so actually what happened to give
you the full chronological order of this
whole thing is
three weeks ago i was uh having brunch i
never go out we'd never go out anymore
we
we cook all the time and we love to cook
around here we never go up but we had
friends in from out of town
we ended up going out to brunch and on
the drive home from brunch
was a trump rally i had no idea that
there had been these trump rallies in
beverly hills you know i randomly seen
some pictures but i didn't realize it
was like a weekly thing like that
and we saw the trump rally and we were
like all right we just got to get out
like let's just see what it is because
you're not going to believe this guys i
don't really trust the mainstream media
and when they tell you that all the
people there are white supremacists and
mean
bad deplorable people well i wanted to
see it for myself you know do some
old-fashioned
fact checking anyway we parked we had to
park a couple blocks away because it was
jam-packed and and we went there and
then most of you saw
the video because i went back so two
weeks ago i went back and i did a video
which if you haven't seen we posted on
right here on youtube so you can take a
look at that and
what i saw was absolutely amazing i i
saw
happy fun curious
cool funky weird people of every stripe
black white gay hispanic christian jew
muslim blah blah blah everybody just
having a good time
proud to support america american flags
everywhere
trump flags people arguing about
politics
but happy to do it people that were
there just kind of looking around like
oh there's others
there's others actually when i went back
just this past saturday one of the
interesting things that i thought
was for any of you that have ever been
to a gay pride parade especially when
when you go i think when you're a
younger person and you suddenly see that
there are other people out there not
that there are other people who maybe
feel something that you feel or think
something that you feel
and that putting aside i'm not even i'm
not comparing trumpism to
to being gay or something like that but
you get what i'm saying like when you
just go and suddenly there's a lot of
people you're like oh they kind of think
something that i think and you're kind
of shocked that they're there that's
what it used to feel like when i when i
went to gay pride parades
years ago i've been in a long time um
and that's kind of what the trump thing
felt like like you can't believe oh my
god these are people who live in l.a
these are people who maybe live in
beverly hills
uh and there's all sorts of people here
and it's so the reverse of what the
media says so anyway so i went back
this past saturday and it was absolutely
massive
i don't know how many thousands of
people there but all the cars honking
all the flags flying all the stuff you
know everybody's
saying hi to me uh there was a great
girl savannah if you're watching
she brought don't burn this book which i
signed for or i even remember your name
and i took selfies with a million people
and all that anyway we were we were
there for about 15 minutes and then i
heard a rumor someone came up to me and
was like did you hear that
dennis prager is going to be here so i i
texted
dennis's wife and i said are you guys
coming and they had just parked and i so
i met
dennis a little bit outside of the
of the parade the festivities whatever
you want to call it the rally
and uh we walked in together and i did
do a periscope video of this and we were
going to put it on youtube but there
were so many phones there that i think
the system was overloaded so the quality
the quality is pretty beat up but you
can find it on twitter if you want to
see it
and we went in there and dennis being
there i mean it's nice that a lot of
people recognize me that i'm happy to
say hi
people and take pictures and all that
stuff but dennis it was as if trump
himself trump himself
got there people were chanting and
screaming there was a group of like 50
guys doing a dance around dennis
and and it was hot and it was sunny and
everyone's sweating and just a piece
some people had mass some people didn't
have masks
anyway i'm telling you all of this
because i think it's just
important if you haven't fully figured
it out yet
the stuff that they're telling you the
stuff that they're showing you
it's just not real it's just not real
and the the trump rallies that are
happening
thousands and thousands and thousands of
good people and by the way if there were
the other thing if there were biden
rallies with thousands and thousands of
people
uh i and and one would have been local
to me i would have attended to
i suspect it would have been a lot less
fun and probably far
less welcoming for me but i would have
attended and i would have talked about
it
as honestly as i possibly could there
just aren't any rallies you know you get
kamala showing up in front of six
six people socially distance or biden
showing up in front of four cars that
are socially distance or this
this video of obama giving a speech i'm
not even maybe he was in pennsylvania
i'm not totally sure
where he's literally just standing in
front of like five people i mean
they they're the posters and all the
media and everything else they're
telling us don't
see what you can actually see don't see
all those thousands of people out there
and of course
someone attending a rally is not it's
not a significant
it's not an automatic um recognition
that that person is going because one
person has big rallies and one person
doesn't
but if you just talk about the the
grassroots support the excitement on one
side
versus whatever it is on the other side
and there is a level of excitement on
the other side and what that level of
excitement is actually
is that wolf blitzer even tweeted out
that in dc they're boarding up
all of the restaurants and stores and
all that and that's happening right here
in la by the way and it's happening in
portland and seattle and new york and
all that
because we know i mean without question
if trump wins there is going to be crazy
violence
this is what the left has sort of
unearthed and basically said
is okay so when we had all of the riots
a couple months ago
uh because of black lives matter and
george floyd and antifa and all that
it was like the left was basically
saying yeah you're allowed to do this
and violence is in violence and if you
destroy property that's not violence and
you can stop people from
getting on a bridge or going down the
road or whatever you want to do
because we've got to fight systemic
racism which which doesn't even exist
although they're trying to put it on the
ballot here in california which i talked
about the other day
um we know that there will be violence
and and it i mentioned the wolf blitzer
tweet on this
uh which we should have pulled up but
you guys can you guys can snag it right
now if you're if you're on twitter
um because the implication is that oh
they're boarding up because there's
gonna be violence and violence is sort
of a 50 50 thing like
violence could come from either side for
any reason everything else but
we know like i don't think you have to
think i'm um
some mad genius to know that obviously
if trump wins
the the anti-fog crew the progressives
like they will they will
unleash hell they they will it just it
just is that's what they've done that's
what they've promised to do
and by the way there will be no
democrats that that try to stop it
two days later they'll give half-assed
statements but in a weird way they'll be
cheered on it right
they'll be cheered they'll be cheering
on the the thing okay
that's number one now try to try to
figure out the reverse let's say biden
wins let's say biden wins tomorrow and
it really is conclusive
right not not even contested biden wins
in a landslide
you know he wins 48 states the the
popular vote like it's all there
do you think trump supporters are going
to be out on the streets
burning down cities burning down their
towns destroying
uh wendy's and targets like no
do you think they'll be attacking small
businesses and attacking people on the
streets
the answer is no but i know a lot of
people
don't see that like if you watch
mainstream media you
kind of think it's a 50 50 thing or you
think that these
white christian militias are roaming the
streets to threaten people i mean it
just doesn't exist
it doesn't exist yet there's a certain
set of people that believe that it does
and that's that's pretty freaking
dangerous and of course that gets back
to the war on reality that i've been
talking about that depending on what
you're listening to
and who you're listening to uh you may
view the world in in very different
situations so look it's going to be an
interesting
i was going to say i was going to say 48
hours i was going to say 24 hours but
that just gets us to tomorrow morning
and 48 hours just gets us to uh
to wednesday morning it's going to be an
interesting situation here for however
long it takes to pan out i do want to
say a couple other things you know look
in the last few weeks i obviously
publicly said that i was going to
support trump i think i've
in the last year i think in many ways if
for any of you that have watched my
political evolution and you could quite
literally find videos
from a little about four and a half
years ago where i was supporting bernie
right and i was a progressive and a
lefty and as you guys know i was on the
young turks and blah blah blah
four years ago i supported gary johnson
because i really despised hillary
and i really didn't want to vote for
trump
and i thought well i'm here in
california and i mostly line up with
libertarian ideas so this is sort of a
protest vote
um i don't think you can do a protest
vote this time
you know i just don't see how that's
legit i mean obviously for whatever
negligible momentum or visibility
gary johnson had i mean joe jorgensen
has just had absolutely nothing right
gary johnson at least as the third party
guy had a couple moments the where's
aleppo moment
either not being able to name a foreign
leader moment i mean they weren't good
moments but there were moments where
people were like oh i know who
gary johnson is now i have joe jorgensen
on the show i think she's a perfectly
lovely person
you guys know my feelings about
libertarian ideas i just think that this
time around the rubber has met the road
like which way do you want america to go
do you want america to
tomorrow or on january 20th
be anything close to the america that
has existed for over 250 years
do you want america to be something that
it is proud of
do you want capitalism to continue do
you want
the the constitution to be a document
that continues to govern us and the bill
of rights and the branches of government
do you want some level of patriotism and
pride in this operation
or do you want to reverse all of those
things and i want to be very clear about
this because people say dave every time
you say that
biden doesn't want to reverse all of
these things again guys biden
is just the host biden is sigourney
weaver and what lays within her stomach
is an
evil alien that will burst forth once he
is in the white house
biden obviously has dementia or
something else
he has flummoxed and flubbered and
fallen over words and sentences and
gotten lost
in all of those things i don't mean that
to be glib as i keep saying there are
times when i do mean it to be glib
because it's so ridiculous
i can't get one blue czech publicly
influential
person on the left to get go on the
record and say they don't think
something's wrong with him
so you've got all of these people who
are supposedly enlightened right like
these enlightened bright
educated political people and they're
all they all
knowingly are supporting someone that
they think is something has some
cognitive problems like
that strikes me as a bit of a of a moral
quandary or a bit of a
internal problem right um but again
biden himself is not the thing the thing
is the thing that's coming
behind him so let's talk about the thing
that's coming behind him because it is
very much linked
to his running mate kamala harrison you
guys know my feelings about her and i'm
sure most of you watch the vp debates
i think she's deeply unlikable but that
that just sort of is what it is there's
an entitled
heir to her don't talk when i'm talking
and i'm talking now and
you know there's that cackle and all of
that stuff okay fine
she posted a video which i referenced
earlier she posted this video
yesterday about equity on twitter it's a
little animated video and i and there's
subtitles
and and keep your audio up watch this
video and then we're going to discuss it
after and if you think
four or five years ago when i was saying
guys there's something wrong with the
left
and liberalism and leftism have nothing
to do with each other anymore
and these people are actually counter to
american values and i've laid my out my
case over the last couple years very
honestly i think
um i i felt it was always gonna come
down to this so now we're literally
she posted this yesterday two days
before the election in essence
coming out as the most woke marxist you
possibly could
let's take a look at the video so
there's a big difference between
equality and equity
a quality suggests oh everyone should
get the same amount
the problem with that not everybody's
starting out from the same place
so if we're all getting the same amount
but you started out back there and i
started out over here
we could get the same amount but you're
still going to be that far back behind
me
it's about giving people the resources
and the support they need
so that everyone can be on equal footing
and then compete
on equal footing equitable treatment
means we all end up at the same
[Music]
lordy lordy we gotta talk okay there's a
lot there it opens up by saying there's
a big difference
between equality and equity everyone
should get the same amount
uh no everyone shouldn't get the same
amount you want equality meaning that
everyone is
living under the same laws so that they
have the opportunity
to pursue whatever they want they have
the opportunity to pursue happiness
right
uh life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness so you want laws to make sure
you have a chance to do that
so so the very first sentence of the
thing in essence is wrong
everyone should get the same amount
that's not really what america is about
getting the same amount as if it's the
government's job to get
you something it's your job to get you
something and almost everything that is
good and worth getting
is because individual people have had
individual ideas and have built
companies and businesses
and tv shows and comedies
and products and whatever it might be
and then
pursued that on their own terms and
made good things that have inspired
people to do that again
that's a beautiful thing about
capitalism so she's she's mistaken right
at the beginning equality
is not about that everyone should get
the same amount equality is saying
we're going to give you equal
opportunity equal laws and it
she is right about one thing not
everyone starts at the same place so
let's discuss that because that seems to
be a little bit of a confusion
not everyone is born in the exact same
place to everyone watching this right
now i was born in a different set of
circumstances than you were and you were
born in a different
set of circumstances then everyone and
by the way often even within your own
family
one sibling might be brought up when the
parents were doing really well and there
was only one kid
and they might have gotten a bunch more
and had more attention and everything
else
and then maybe one of the parents lost
their job or there was a divorce or
someone became an alcoholic or a series
of other things
and then the second kid grows up in a
potentially broken family
has parents that aren't available as
much maybe they had to move to a
different town where the schools aren't
as good i mean
the idea that we should all be right
here at the big
it's so crazy it's anti-human guys
that's the thing that you need to
understand when they're pushing this
idea
of equity on you they are doing
something is that is anti-human
the idea we're all going to start off in
the same place it is literally
impossible unless you want to
just destroy everybody that you can
maybe bring up the i mean you can't do
it you'd have to kill an awful lot of
people but that we'd start at the same
place but then what was the most
dangerous part of what she said
was that we'll all end up at the same
place can you
imagine a world like that what do you
mean we'll all end up in the same place
so do you think that elon musk who is
sending us to mars and building
underground tunnels in los angeles and
who is a
you know one of the leading geniuses of
our time or
or henry ford or albert einstein
or anyone or is michael jordan should
michael jordan have ended up in the
exact same place as some guy
who has no talent whatsoever and doesn't
work very hard in the rest of it of
course not but
this is why it is anti-human what they
are telling you they are telling we're
going to start you at the same place
which is an
absolute impossibility and then we're
going to get you to the same place and
then you know they have a bird and
they're on a
you know the sun is there and you know
they're on a hill and it sort of sounds
nice
but this is the great trick that the
left has pulled with people
and it and for the average person
watching that i suppose she tweets that
out and it got a lot of traction and
people go oh this sounds so nice
this sounds so nice i guess we will
takes from some because some people have
a little bit more you know you could be
born
rich you could be born rich and you
could blow it all you could be born with
nothing
what story do we all love what story is
like the quintessential american story
the family that came here with nothing
or the kid that grew up in the project
and then became
something right like became something
that
that is what we love we love the story
of overcoming and what they're saying is
we can somehow rejigger the system so
that you'll start in the same place and
end in the same place it's anti-human
and it's and it's scary actually and
this that she released this video that
they felt this was the right video to
release
uh 48 hours before the election like
really unmask
this stuff we are woke marxist and does
does joe biden believe in any of that i
mean
look what did joe biden do without
getting into the whole hunter biden
laptop and everything else
joe biden gave his son access to all
sorts of things that made his son
an incredible amount of money right now
he did that because
his son is his son and he was a very
influential guy right i'm not even
getting into all the specifics
of the scandal right it almost seems
like that that train has
has left the station already but he did
it to put his son with the best
opportunity to flourish or whatever else
and then hunter obviously
had a series of problems but if joe
believed that everyone should start at
the same place then why did he give his
son
the connections to get the big job at
barisma and everything else
why didn't he give it to some random
person right because nobody believes
this
nobody actually believes in this stuff
for themselves
they believe in it for other people and
this is so consistent with basically
everything progressives do about
everything gavin newsom his kids go to
private school he's the governor of
california right
elizabeth warren her kids go to private
school and then she'll
also rail against school choice the
the level of hypocrisy is absolutely off
the charts and i think this is the
reason i wanted to play this
is because look how it's packaged it's
so pleasant
and it's so obviously good what they're
not telling you is when they're
raising that first guy it's not that
they're raising him because you know how
you get raised you get raised
in the system through hard work through
education
through family through a belief system
through all of those things
all that that this country can do for
you
is what it has guaranteed us from the
beginning which is that
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness will protect your life we're
gonna make you know hopefully you're not
gonna be shot when you walk out of your
house
liberty you can live free and hopefully
do what you want to do
these are somewhat um they're sort of
vague terms at some level because that
the responsibility is on you
and then you can pursue your happiness
but the idea
you're gonna we're gonna lift you no
we're not lifting anyone what we're
gonna do is destroy people
but that's also secondary to the end of
that thing you
don't i don't think anyone watching this
please correct me if i'm wrong do you
want to live in a society
where we all end up in the same place
we're
it's it's the reverse of the human mind
it's the reverse of human ingenuity it's
the reverse of what history is
and that's what's on the ballot i hate
to tell you that's what's on the ballot
so here we are so it's like you can
either be for that
or you can be for the imperfect
fairly corrupt new york city businessman
who's orange
but for some reason has been tasked with
saving the union
and it sort of seems to be like a task
that he's up to and he's woken up enough
people and as i said to glenn beck
on his podcast a couple days ago trump
started mapping
how do you fight these people and win
instead of being a republican that
fights them and loses like john mccain
or mitt romney and that's not a knock on
either one of them as a person
they tried to do it a certain way it
didn't work and trump said i'm going to
do it the other way
but what they're telling you is
we want you to be the same at the
beginning and the same at the end
absolutely impossible and then what are
we also going to do well as i talked
about last week california has a
proposition right now to put
systemic racism back in the system they
will look
at your ethnicity and your skin color
and your gender and your sexuality when
the government of california is hiring
if this proposition is passed that is
what we got rid of with the 1964 civil
rights act now we're going to put it
back in in the name of tolerance
so the tolerance of today is the
intolerance of 1964.
you guys get it yet that is what is on
the ballot right now while donald trump
you know what he's been doing
he was getting critical race theory out
of the the federal government he was
getting title
ix out of the universities the choice is
yours i mean the choice just seems
so obvious it just seems so obvious to
me
and and i'll say something else which is
you know we will get out of this thing
like i don't think and
you could find videos of me back in
march when the lockdown was starting i
was saying
literally a week into it the old world
is not coming back
i think a lot of people think that if if
joe
biden becomes president that somehow the
old world that we remember
whatever that was even though it feels
like a dream or it was or sleepwalking
or something at the moment
it's like i think people think oh if we
can just get this old guy back in who
was around for 47 years he acts like a
politician he's
old something about obama if we can just
get that guy back in like the old system
will come back
guys that system is not coming back the
world is deeply changed forever
between the the way we've acquiesced our
individual liberty and
allowed these lockdowns to continue uh
between the the amount of big tech
uh the amount of power that big tech has
over us
all of these things the way the
mainstream media has been completely
unmasked you know so it's like when when
there's
a riot and there's a zillion people out
on the streets
and it's uh they'll say oh this is
there'll literally be articles about how
nobody got coveted because of that you
know what i mean because they're outside
and it's fresh air or something but then
they'll
the same uh organizations will tell you
oh trump rally super spread event like
it's
everything has been exposed everything
is up there and there's incredible
opportunity in that by the way and that
that's one of the reason i'm
reasons i'm not a hysterical lunatic
right now like i'm actually feeling very
good about the world i'm
nervous about what could happen tomorrow
and i'm definitely nervous look if biden
wins and
all of these horrible ideas are injected
back into the government and the
mainstream media which has been so
awful and negligent uh if they're
empowered again
and then you see what some of these
people are talking about with truth and
reconciliation commissions and they'd
love to have lists of people
and and the rest of it and we'll talk
about lists in just a sec
um there's there's dangerous stuff on
the horizon for sure but if you want to
think if
you're let's say you're on the fence
right now right again it's always that
that's little sliver of people that
still haven't figured out
what they want to do well i think you
know what happens biden comes in
and you never you never really get back
but we've empowered
what i would say are all the bad forces
the forces of big government the forces
of big
tech the forces of of all of the of big
media like all of that stuff becomes
empowered
and in the last four years it got
weakened and that was actually good
but that does bring some of the chaos
that exists right now but that that's
sort of what had to happen it was going
to be a byproduct of it
if trump wins i think that there is a
chance
that in a second term trump will feel
emboldened enough
and and not only trump but average
people will feel bold enough
we're done with cancel culture we're not
playing this stupid game anymore
we're done with the nonsensical bs
partisan mainstream media like all of
them will be unmasked
i think there will be a resurgence of
patriotism in america
um i think i think all of these people
always say oh but the europeans hate us
now the rest of the world's laughing at
us
i don't think it's true and even if it
was true frankly i wouldn't care i care
what i think of me and my
my co-americans my my brothers and
sisters think of me i'm not worried
about
what what europeans are thinking i think
there's a chance we could we could start
opening the country again it would be
it would would there be risk yes there
would be risk there is risk when you
walk outside of your house you might get
hit by a car
but i think there could actually be a
resurgence of something good
something that we don't even really
maybe understand something that would be
akin to like maybe like a reagan
style you know remember rocky iv when
you could
freaking fly the flag and it was like
america you were proud to be an american
like i think
i think people are ready for that again
it only comes one way
it does not come through equity it does
not come through the 1619 project it
does not come
through running around saying half of
your
fellow citizens are bigots and racists
and all of that right for all the
frustrations i have
with these leftist ideas like i think
the average person's just confused and i
want to show them there's a there's a
better way
and i do think there's a better way um
but but
if you if you map the future in a
different way than i do i'd love to hear
it i really would love to hear it like
if you think somehow biden winning
leads us to more freedom and that we
won't be in endless lockdown to just
told what to do and that big tech would
be more empowered to silence people if
you don't think any of those things are
true
then i'd love to hear it but i think
there's a chance that like we really can
get
past this thing like it's it just feels
like it's all been leading up to this
election and if we can break through now
then maybe there really is a chance that
that's the way i see it that's the way
uh that's what leaves me without feeling
crazy all the time
and and also hearing from you guys that
a lot of you feel the same way
uh so let's just let's just do one more
thing um which is it's sort of election
related because it's covert related and
everything's kind of
election related and uh and actually
before i get to it
i should tell you guys that tomorrow i'm
gonna be live in studio during the
election at the beginning of the evening
with the daily wire guys
uh then i'm gonna come back home i'm
gonna do some some stuff with the blaze
people
we'll probably do a short live stream
right here on youtube just a solo one
i'll just get you up to date
on on where things are at and what i'm
thinking about things and then we will
do one later in the evening when
hopefully there's
a result or at least something to really
really talk about
if nothing else maybe we'll talk about
just the instruction the implosion or
the destruction of the media i mean that
would be fine too
uh so probably two live streams on the
reuben report channel and i'll be with
the daily wire guys and the blaze guys
and maybe some other surprises
um real quick though this third story
it's important to get to so gretchen
whitmer
is the governor of uh michigan she's the
one
that didn't want at the beginning of
lockdown you weren't allowed to plant
plants outside of your house remember
that
meanwhile she was found i think it was
her husband's birthday party on a boat
with a bunch of people and no masks okay
fine where nobody's perfect
though she's obviously getting botox
throughout this thing that she's got a
tight a tighter face than cher
well now she is requiring restaurants to
take the
names of customers beginning this monday
or the restaurants will face
a thousand dollar fine remember i talked
about lists
it's like the idea you go to a
restaurant we're gonna put you on a list
and then why wouldn't we show up at your
house and make sure you're
at your house when we think you should
be at your house do you see
what is coming guys we are we are
outsourcing
all of our freedoms to a bunch of people
who are not
good you know what i mean like i don't
know what is in her heart does she
in in whitmer's heart in gavin newsom's
cold heart
in in cuomo's heart do they really think
they're doing good or
are they sort of drunk on power do they
not really know what they're doing
so they just take every opportunity to
get more power
i think that is probably it that's what
these people do
cuomo i mean think about andrew cuomo
this man we
know he sent covid patients back into
nursing homes
and i think correct me if i'm wrong i
think around 30 000 people died because
of that
then he dares to write a freaking book
on leadership
uh in a time of coronavirus which he
wrote right he didn't write it obviously
he didn't write it
but he dares to promote it as if as if
he was a leader that we should
that we should be looking to these these
people are actually dangerous and that
doesn't mean that trump is right about
everything and it doesn't mean the
republicans are right about everything
the republicans i don't consider myself
a republican
i'm voting for trump because i think he
is the best guy to break this freaking
system
i think he is the guy that will give us
the best chance of fighting back against
lockdowns of letting us be free again of
letting political incorrectness
be cool again remember when political
inc incorrectness was cool
right bill maher had a show called
politically incorrect because that was
the cool stuff well now these comedians
including bill maher
have just become a bunch of hysterical
anti-trump nut bags right
it's like we can get past this thing i
think
i think trump's the opportunity to do it
um i do want to say one other thing
though before we uh before we wrap
you know when i started this talk you
know let's say in the last year as
as i think it became more obvious for
those of you that were watching the show
there were i would see comments and
people say oh it seems like dave's gonna
vote for trump or
dave seems to be heading in that
direction or something like that
um you know and i was trying to be sort
of careful about my language
because i wanted to because i
i wanted to be fair and decent and and
something like that right like
and there's also this thing that if you
say you're voting for trump immediately
you get this onslaught of people oh
you're maga you're racist blah blah and
i was trying to do something in a
measured way
the way that i would do normally the way
i would deal with any other topic right
um but i do want to say that in the last
couple weeks and you know trump tweeted
about me
about two weeks ago and then again a
couple days ago
and by the way it's not just me that
didn't vote for trump last time
in the public sphere that is voting for
trump this time as i said the other day
tim poole
who's obviously hugely influential is
doing it ben shapiro did not vote for
trump last time he is
glenn beck is uh he did not clay travis
he did not i mean a series of people
that are that are fairly influential in
whatever this world is
have made the same calculation as i have
and i assure you it's not because we're
racists that it's not because we're
bigots
or anything else or because we want to
oppress people or be mean to trans
people or anything else it's because we
think he's the best
vehicle to to make this country free to
free again to make it return to its
roots and it does
it does it seem like a sci-fi movie or a
weird
a really weird mystery book or something
that it's donald trump
that's doing it yeah it does it does
feel kind of weird but the thing that i
wanted to mention
is that i just want to say this this has
not been without cost you know i i
obviously have a lot of you that that
support me and that's great and the
reubenreport.com community is is blowing
up and i love
connecting with you guys there and as i
said when i went to the rally i get to
meet tons of you guys
and people hug me out of nowhere and you
know say i've had something to do with
their political awakening
although usually they credit larry elder
for beating me senseless
and then i guess i was just sitting
there when it happened and then whatever
um but so this has had great rewards for
me and as i've
told you guys i've built a great
business here and i'm thrilled to work
with the people i work with and do what
i do i wake up with purpose and all that
but i do want to say it's also come with
the serious cost
and i've really seen that cost in the
last couple weeks
because it has affected my relationships
with friends with some family members
i know it's affected even people that
are around me that
are thought of as you know friends of
mine then they get
hit oh now ruben's supporting trump are
you are you a trump supporter like
and and in another way it's like well
that is exactly why
you vote to end this thing you vote to
end this monster that has created this
situation
uh because i have not ended friendships
because of politics and i will always go
out of my way not to do it you know i
played that video of don lemon
last week getting rid of friends because
they think differently i
i go out of my way not to do it and it's
difficult
it really is difficult at times right
when people are
hysterical and whatever but but i just
want to say that there has been some
cost here because i see because it ain't
easy and i know what a lot of you are
going through
whether you've officially said you're
you're voting for trump
or you haven't said it or or whatever it
might be
um you know i think it's your duty i
tweeted this out this morning like
when you're done with this video just
pull up frank sinatra is my way
it's like listen to the lyrics of that
song i think it is your duty
as a human being and as an american
especially to
do what you think say what you feel like
you must do that that's why i did that
video
a few months ago the bravery deficit for
prageru that so many people
don't do that in what at least still
today is the freest country in the world
maybe it won't be starting tomorrow
but it is right now and if you won't
say what you think if you won't tell the
world who you are and what you feel and
and it's your right to vote for whoever
you want to vote for and if you're gonna
be cowed and and fearful of friends and
family members who are going to turn on
you
because you've come to some logical or
decent conclusion by yourself well then
then we've already lost
so i don't think we've lost yet and that
doesn't mean it's it's not
easy and i hear that from you guys all
the time and i just wanted to say that
because i know it in my own life as well
and uh and we could all probably be a
little bit better and i know
that no matter what happens tomorrow
we're gonna need some people to be a
little bit better
and i will try to be one of those people
uh but
we will continue this tomorrow i will be
live at 11 o'clock as always
uh we'll we'll see how the day is shaken
out then as i said two live streams
tomorrow
we'll figure out the exact times on that
i'm then i'm with the daily wire guys
i'm with the blaze guys and and i hope
you get out there and vote
and and i hope you express whatever you
feel
and and don't don't be afraid of it uh
because the more
the more that you're afraid of it the
more that it will prey on you so why
don't we push back a little bit and see
what happens
all right i'm gonna go get a sandwich
enjoy the rest of the day
i hope you do too and i'll see you
tomorrow
you